happy i'm happy
to smell that
my name is george moats it's my job to
make sure you
love hamburgers almost as much as i do
i've been on a mission to preserve the
american hamburger and what i've noticed
is that a lot of the
big commercial fast food places have
given the hamburger a bad rap
today i want to focus on two family
owned
locally beloved fast food icons fatmo's
in nashville and a place called swensons
in northeast ohio
these regional burger chains have proven
that you don't have to sell out
to be a success pow that's right sorry
and listen it's very important to
remember that both these places have
secrets
these are not their recipes i'm giving
you this is an approximation
of what i think they might be doing i
don't want to hear your secrets your
secrets are important to you they keep
you relevant
but the two burgers that i'm going to be
making today take a few twists and turns
to get to the finished product
these are pretty unique burgers you
ready let's go for a ride
we're going through regional american
fast food burger history let's do this
we are here to talk about swensons ohio
is a great
place for primary source hamburger
joints also the birthplace
of wendy's uh it's the home of white
castle
swestis is the pride of northeast ohio
it's the kind of place
where nostalgia is an ingredient you
taste it you feel it
it's as if time went on and left
swenson's in the past
in a good way swenson's is also a
classic drive-in it's not a
drive-through
to drive in what's the difference how
about a little history lesson here
the drive-in was not originally intended
for the burger concept
it began in 1921 when jesse kirby took
advantage of the automotive boom and
opened a chain of drive-in
pig stands in dallas texas this novel
concept allowed for hungry customers to
drive up place their order with a car
hop
eat and leave without ever having to get
out of their vehicle this food delivery
system was eventually adopted by
hamburger restaurants
nationwide the drive through came nearly
30 years later thanks to in-and-out's
founder harry snyder
snyder wanted to speed up the ordering
process for his southern california
burger operation
which at the time only had a drive up
window where people would place an order
and wait in a stroke of genius snyder
figured out a way to build a cheap
two-way radio
which allowed the customer to pull up
place an order at the curb and have the
food be ready by the time they got to
the window
the drive-through was adapted by
virtually all the fast food nationwide
which of course spelled doom for the
drive-in
this stuff still happens at swensons i
took my teenage daughter there for the
first time
and she was blown away by what she saw
what they're doing is something that no
one does anymore they're running
from the kitchen to a car and back to
the kitchen at top speed because that's
the way it was done back then
you worked hard for your tips when
people ask me what to get
at swenson's i tell them you have to get
the signature burger the galley boy
i'm ready you ready who's ready i'm
ready who's ready you ready i'm ready
let's make this
the construction is simple it's just two
beef patties a slice of cheese in
between the two
kind of like the big mac and bob's big
boy double decker barbecue sauce a
tangy tartar sauce and that's it they
grind their own beef and make their own
patties
and i think i know why starting to lose
lips on the interwebs
mention that there might be some brown
sugar
mixed into the beef so i tried that
and it works actually they will not
confirm this or deny this
but i can tell you right now it was a
pretty unique flavor
but something goes on there some weird
science is happening whenever you
combine
sugar and beef this burger
what am i doing i like to hand smash you
don't have a smashing tool
the tricks i like to use is something
called the hand smash two pieces of
parchment paper
and your hand two patties
[Music]
okay nicely round yes
not too much sugar oh but i can
definitely smell it
oh yeah oh wow they like sugar cookies
one patty two patties hello bun
toasted bun watch closely what happens
here this burger is all about method
in the construction i need to wear my
[ __ ] spatulas
flip a patty flip the second pet now
very important only one slice of cheese
here so one patty gets a slice of cheese
the other patty gets barbecue sauce the
tartar sauce
goes onto the crown of the bun they heal
the bun
watch ready barbecue sauce patty
down see that then
very important the cheese top patty
down and the crown of the bun goes on
top of that
you heard that on top so now you have oh
[ __ ]
very hot fun oh [ __ ] is hot now you have
tartar sauce patty chip oh
jesus christ tartar sauce patty cheese
patty barbecue sauce right the whole
thing gets wrapped up
toothpick and just like they do
they take a toothpick and they seat the
whole thing together
and into that toothpick they stick
look at that they stick a pimento
stuffed
olive there it is the galley boy from
swenson's just like you'd find it
but now it's been sitting here for a
couple of minutes oh
look at that
that's a thing of beauty this is a
homemade
galley boy you know what it looks like
the real thing
um
on the nashville here we go the double
mo
the double cheeseburger at a place in
nashville called fat moe's
fat moe's is not a sit down restaurant
it's a drive up restaurant you actually
drive
up to the window and order a window old
school it's about as old school as it
gets
you get the burger it looks like a
classic american cheeseburger
but there's a twist there's a twist here
the owners are from iran and flavors
are persian that's right if you imagine
that it's a perfect mashup between
a classic american double cheeseburger
and persian
spice of course behind every great
burger there's usually a pretty crazy
story from what i understand
a guy named muhammad in 1970s in tehran
opened up a chain of hamburger stands
called mamatopal
which translated from farsi means fat
muhammad when the shah of iran was
deposed in 1978
he felt it was unsafe for he and his
family to be there so they left
and went to of all places nashville he
had a cousin there
when he got to nashville he immediately
opened up another mini chain
of hamburger joints called fat bows this
burger's all about method
and that's why i love it like most good
regional burgers there's some kind of
method involved that makes it special
in this case similar to the teriyaki
burger in hawaii
the patty is dipped into a marinade at
some point in the cooking process
this is a marinade that has according to
all the news reports and what they've
actually told me personally
there's 18 spices in that it's a secret
obviously we didn't want to ask them
what their secrets were
i don't want to hear secrets we knew
that it had cumin we knew that it had
cardamom but
beyond that we didn't know so we started
asking people asking friends
and a bunch of friends of mine came back
with what they thought might be
a perfect 18 spice marinade so
in this we have i read
coriander cumin cinnamon black pepper
cardamom
nutmeg lemon peel saffron sumac
mace ginger oregano cloves
sesame dried mint dried parsley turmeric
and you ready for this one crushed rose
petals
that's right crushed rose petals it'll
easily be the first burger i've ever
made
with crushed rose petal spice in it is
it a spice i guess it is
fat moz uses fresh ground beef but i'm
going to use
these hand smash method
look at that patty down
second patty we're making a double
it down salt
i'm gonna flip already i gotta flip
gotta flip
wow i don't wanna cook too much it's
going to go back on the flat top again
so right now i'm just going to oh [ __ ]
out
sorry i burned myself again what's wrong
with me into the marinade
look at that the marinade is warm it's
sitting on the flat top
and it's warm it's cooked
it's such crazy science but it totally
works oh yeah
hot stuff oh
jesus never [ __ ] learned man so in
addition to these 18 spices i did add
beef broth
as a liquid component okay i think it's
been about three minutes i'm going to go
ahead and
return these patties to the flat top
oh it always smells oh my god
oh yeah
whoo you smell that put a mustard in the
bottom
some lettuce on top of that patties go
down
one pate two patties slice of tomato
pickles on top of that slick the top bun
with mayonnaise
put it all together look at that
now the real trick here is gonna be to
do this
yeah i'm gonna tuck this under
tuck this under fold it under wham look
at that
complete with an 18
18 spice marinade
it smells like nothing you've ever
smelled before
oh my god happy i'm happy
the hyper regional fast food burger
thank you fat moes
thank you swedsens thank you for keeping
it real
and keeping alive because then i get to
eat this stuff
so do you
see you next time when i may do it
shirtless
no just kidding
hey my name is george moats don't forget
to like and subscribe to first we feast
and get more episodes of burger scholar
right here
where